so given what Chucky's capabilities are
in this movie I'm curious what is your
technology vice how does he get to you
based on what you use on an everyday
basis and I realize yeah I mean my phone
my phone is gonna kill me my phone is
already killing me it's turning me into
a zombie you are not the only one it's a
psychological takedown I don't use my
phone that often but I use my I'm on my
laptop like constantly it's just what is
the weirdest piece of technology you use
that would come and get you a cure again
my dear sir in it that's all of my light
bulbs in my house are hooked up to the
hugh phillips app so i feel like they
could very easily just burst into flames
and burn me alive well this is creating
some interesting visuals i feel like
this is child's play meets final
destination and I'm okay with that
not gonna be through so this is your
first horror movie in a way life after
bed has some horror elements to it dirty
grandpa well but in in a sense maybe
yeah yeah really you're super
experienced so I'm curious did you have
any advice for Aubrey before jumping
into this no I don't really go into
horror films or any genre thank you that
I'm gonna play the character differently
because of its genre I think it just
really depends on each character and the
script but Gabriel would hide in the
shadows and in my closet and darkness
that was my pop out at me to scare me
and make me scream everyday so he
created a culture of terror while we
were shooting
as you said oh yeah I could imagine yeah
does anything scare you anymore Lee
especially with the different variety of
films you've done are you scared of a
slasher or paranormal uh I don't know I
I don't you really get scared in horror
films anymore
I mean I do if it's like something that
I feasibly could happen and if it's like
smart [ __ ] rather than just like
characters making stupid decisions yeah
I don't know like psychological
thrillers like slow burn maybe something
like that that's the benefit of this
kind of horror it's fun and it's playful
you get a little exhilaration out of it
and it's not real yeah wouldn't be yeah
I guess you never know that is what it's
chipping away at right now yeah this is
also your first time playing a mother so
I was wondering if there was anything
about that that came as a surprise to
you um well you know when I read the
script I I was so excited to play a
young mom because my mom in real life
was 20 when she had me and the age
difference was the same in the movie
between those characters so I was like
actually I really connected this
character and yeah I don't know about
not surprising but I think like it was a
check it is a challenge to play someone
whose child is who you think is losing
their mind you know and how do you play
that how do you make that real that was
that was a challenge and speaking about
the environment on-site you were hiding
around so you're creating the
appropriate environment to really know I
I hear there's pranks happening on this
one yeah I was watching one of the
behind-the-scenes featurettes and you
had said something like Lara's brought
his Scandinavian military brat back
rents a set and that you're on high
alert all the time so I was just
wondering what that's specifically meant
well
Lara's was in the Norwegian army for six
years and he ran our set it was a very
tight tight ship
whatever he was terrifying at one point
he did bring a sword a Viking sword and
a viking helmet onto set just to remind
everyone who was boss and I was just
little little pranks like that
yeah I think the store does that get
power me to show it was a paramedic it
was a real sword - yeah it was illegal
you're not allowed to
that okay and he anything goes in Norway
he gave us both hunting knives for he
did oh really
yeah which I actually use last night I
put it on my nightstand because I heard
a noise I'm actually curious now what's
the weirdest rap gift you've ever got if
not that that's oh well oh you Oh
Gabriel gave me a wrap gift that was
basically a doll that he ripped its head
off and then sewed it off back on
backwards and then somehow recorded his
own voice and put it into him into the
doll so when I touch it Gabriel's voice
comes out of it creepiest gift ever that
is so creepy animal restore yeah I've
never gotten a creepy don't be wrapped
it's just like the watermelon ah yes so
what are you looking forward to doing
now do you want to stay in horror you
kind of keeping the door open to
anything that comes yeah find you yeah I
don't really like pick things because of
genre it really just depends on the
character so whatever comes my way that
I think the character is good or the
script is good off we'd be able to take
and I'm curious did you catch the horror
bug at this point because I did hear you
might have been meeting with Zack Snyder
about a really cool project army of the
Dead are you guys gonna be working
together the summer I had who told you
that I don't know I don't know no I just
want to do a love story I just you know
want to do something light-hearted but
I'll do anything
undersea I'm available with the tech
avail I'll do anything I was wondering
what is the very first horror movie you
two both remember being terrified of
either 28 days later or the shining
shining is a good one
shining is a good one mine is actually
on the wall of your bedroom killer
Klowns from outer space I watched it
when I was way too young and I wasn't
able to process that it was a horror
comedy yeah yeah
it was funny yeah I don't know why
poultry guys always sticks out for me
because it was so suburban and like the
trees coming alive and all that stuff
was always scary to me because I grew up
in the suburbs actually speaking of
poltergeists this is obviously an iconic
slasher reboot we're bound to get more
of them I had a very good time with this
movie so I want to know from your
experience making it what advice would
you give to someone else out there who
is bound to reboot yet another slasher
franchise I don't know like I'm not a
huge fan of remaking movies that were
already good but I feel like this movie
is cool because it's a reimagining of
the character so it's not like a
straight remake it's like they they kind
of like updated the character and made
it relevant to kind of like this new
generation so I would say like picture
you know do it for the right reason
don't don't just remake a movie just to
remake it yeah I bet